There is a mini-industry inside journalism right now, one of the few parts of the journalism business that's actually thriving, I think.
目前新闻业内部存在一个微型产业，我认为这是新闻业中为数不多真正蓬勃发展的领域之一。
A reporter's finding unusual signs of the recession all over the place. But that did not prepare me to hear about this side of the recession from a dentist, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], outside Washington, DC.
一位记者在各处都发现了经济衰退的异常迹象。但这并没有让我准备好从华盛顿特区外的一位牙医口中听到经济衰退的这一面。
The biggest thing I've been seeing is broken teeth. I spoke with a buddy of mine who's a dentist up in New York. He's like, man, everybody's cracking teeth. And I said, yeah, I know.
我看到最多的情况是牙齿断裂。我和一个在纽约做牙医的朋友聊过。他说，伙计，每个人的牙齿都在开裂。我说，是的，我知道。
Really acutely I've seen it in the last three or four months. Nightly grinding, clenching. And typically what happens with clenching and grinding, it's transient. It'll come and go, be on and off. But in times of high stress, whether it's in a personal life or in, right now with the economy, everybody's under a lot more stress. You see a lot more people having jaw pain and broken teeth.
在过去三四个月里，我感受得非常明显。夜间磨牙、咬紧牙关。通常情况下，咬牙和磨牙是短暂的。它们会来来去去，断断续续。但在高压时期，无论是个人生活还是现在的经济形势，每个人都承受着更大的压力。你会看到更多的人出现下巴疼痛和牙齿断裂。
On the day we interviewed Dr. [UNINTELLIGIBLE], of 10 patients, two had cracked teeth and one needed a night guard for grinding teeth in their sleep. As for around the country, urologists in New York and Cleveland have reported a rise in vasectomies.
在我们采访那位博士的当天，10个病人中有两个牙齿开裂，一个需要佩戴夜间磨牙护齿套。至于全国各地，纽约和克利夫兰的泌尿科医生报告说输精管切除术有所增加。
Traffic delays dropped by 1/3 last year. Two women in Pennsylvania, in separate incidents, according to newspapers, robbed banks and then immediately went out with the money and bought cashier's checks with the money they had stolen, cashier's checks to pay their rent. Porn video sales are down 10% to 30%, depending on how you measure it.
去年交通延误减少了1/3。据报纸报道，宾夕法尼亚州有两名女性在不同的事件中抢劫了银行，然后立即用偷来的钱去购买保付支票，用来支付房租。色情视频销量下降了10%到30%，具体取决于你的衡量方式。
And shark attacks, yes, shark attacks, are at their lowest point in five years, thanks to the recession. That figure according to the International Shark Attack File at the University of Florida. Fewer people on vacation apparently means fewer people getting bit by sharks.
还有鲨鱼袭击，是的，鲨鱼袭击，由于经济衰退，处于五年来的最低点。这一数据来自佛罗里达大学的国际鲨鱼袭击档案。显然，度假的人少了，意味着被鲨鱼咬伤的人也少了。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, scenes from the recession, including tips on what not to say to somebody who is working at a store that is being liquidated. And we go on a government raid, a government raid on a bad bank. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是经济衰退的场景，包括关于不要对那些正在清算的商店里的员工说什么的建议。我们还将参加一次政府突袭，针对一家坏银行的政府突袭。请继续收听。
Act 1, Is the Condo Half Empty, or is the Condo Half Full?
第一幕，公寓是半空的，还是半满的？
We've all heard about these suburbs in Florida and California and Las Vegas where lots of people took out subprime mortgages just before the housing bubble burst, suburbs where today you have entire neighborhoods where most of the houses are empty. But you hear less about how this is playing out in big cities. And in big cities, the boom and bust took a different form.
我们都听说过佛罗里达、加利福尼亚和拉斯维加斯这些郊区，那里的许多人在住房泡沫破裂前申请了次贷，这些郊区今天有整个社区的大部分房屋都是空的。但你很少听到这在在大城市是如何表现的。在大城市，繁荣与萧条采取了不同的形式。
In Chicago, for instance, you don't see entire neighborhoods vacated, but you also see lots of empty apartment buildings, and half-empty ones, like 1633 W. Farwell in Chicago's Rogers Park neighborhood. Classic old courtyard building. Then at the end of the housing boom, it's being converted into condos, condos with granite countertops and beautiful stainless steel appliances.
例如在芝加哥，你没有看到整个社区空置，但你确实看到了许多空置的公寓楼，还有半空的公寓楼，比如芝加哥罗杰斯公园社区的法尔韦尔西街1633号。经典的旧式庭院建筑。在房地产繁荣末期，它被改造成了公寓，拥有花岗岩台面和漂亮的不锈钢电器。
Until the Chicago housing market collapsed in late 2007, leaving 19 of its 39 units empty.
直到芝加哥房地产市场在2007年底崩溃，其39个单元中有19个空置。
We had had an issue with a squatter in the building. We had a couple of those guys, and I thought it might have just been somebody trying to get back into the unit and camp out and sleep.
我们楼里有个擅自居住的人。我们有几个那样的家伙，我以为可能只是有人试图回到单元里露营和睡觉。
This is Jon Miller, who lives in a first-floor unit, where for days he and his wife would hear this noise, this noise coming from this vacant apartment upstairs from theirs. Then, they'd be lying in bed, and they would hear the sound of crumbling rocks and drywall coming from inside the walls and ceiling. Until finally, the culprit actually came through a big hole in the utility closet and they spotted it, a cat. It was black and it was feral, and it ran back up the hole.
这是乔恩·米勒，他住在一楼。几天来，他和妻子听到这种噪音，这种噪音来自他们楼上那间空置的公寓。后来，他们躺在床上，会听到墙壁和天花板内传出岩石和干墙崩塌的声音。直到最后，罪魁祸首通过衣帽间的一个大洞钻了出来，他们发现了它，是一只猫。它是黑色的，而且是野生的，它又跑回了洞里。
So, I set a trap, which was just a small plate of tuna set 3/4 of the way over the edge of the countertop. And that way I knew, once he jumps up, he starts eating the tuna, he knocks the plate over, it breaks the plate, it wakes me up, I come out, and I've got him.
于是，我设了一个陷阱，只是一个小盘子，放了3/4的吞拿鱼在台面边缘。这样我知道，一旦他跳上来开始吃吞拿鱼，他就会打翻盘子，盘子会碎，把我吵醒，我出来就能抓住他。
Wait, and so then it's you and your wife running around your apartment here, trying to chase a feral cat.
等等，然后就是你和你妻子在公寓里跑来跑去，试图追赶一只野猫。
Yes. We were just digging out clothing, trying to get up under our dressers, trying to get him out from under the bed. And finally, I just was able to grab him.
是的。我们只是在翻找衣服，试图钻到梳妆台下面，试图把他从床底下弄出来。最后，我终于设法抓住了他。
Were you frightened?
你害怕了吗？
By a cat? No.
被猫抓？没有。
Did it bite you?
它咬你了吗？
Yeah, it scratched me pretty good. A pretty good deep one in the leg and a couple on my arm.
是的，它把我抓得很厉害。腿上抓了个很深的伤口，手臂上也有几道。
So to review, the housing market collapsed in Chicago, and as a result, Jon got scratched by a feral cat. He and the other people in this building have done nothing wrong. They didn't take out crazy loans that they couldn't afford. They played by the rules. They've paid their mortgage payments. And yet, they find themselves in an increasingly difficult situation.
回顾一下，芝加哥的房地产市场崩溃了，结果乔恩被一只野猫抓伤了。他和这栋楼里的其他人什么也没做错。他们没有申请他们负担不起的疯狂贷款。他们按规矩行事。他们支付了抵押贷款。然而，他们发现自己陷入了日益困难的境地。
A month after Jon moved in, winter arrived in Chicago in earnest. And with two empty apartments above his, apartments that had no heat because the developer stopped renovations, pipes froze.
乔恩搬进来一个月后，芝加哥迎来了真正的冬天。由于楼上两间空公寓没有暖气，因为开发商停止了翻修，水管冻裂了。
And so, water poured out all over my kitchen floor and basically ruined my kitchen floor. It's wobbly and kind of warped. You can walk across it for yourself.
所以，水流满了我的厨房地板，基本上毁了我的厨房地板。它摇晃而且有点变形。你可以自己走过去试试。
Two other frozen pipes in the building damaged another guy's kitchen, and pretty much destroyed a ground-level apartment across the courtyard from Jon. Now, if Jon sounds unsurprisingly calm about all this, there are two reasons. One, he practices meditation regularly, which, by the way, he'll be glad to tell you about.
楼里另外两条结冰的水管损坏了另一个人的厨房，并且几乎摧毁了乔恩院子对面的一间底层公寓。现在，如果乔恩对这一切听起来异常冷静，有两个原因。第一，他经常练习冥想，顺便说一句，他会很乐意告诉你关于这方面的事。
It's changed my life forever for the better. It'll do the same for you. Swear to God it will.
它永远改变了我的生活，变得更好。它对你也会有同样的效果。我发誓真的会。
But also, he is in the real estate business. And what it means to be in the real estate business these days is that he is a mortgage broker who has seen his own income drop in half, and that has forced a kind of Zen attitude on him.
但同时，他从事房地产行业。这些天在房地产行业意味着他是一名抵押贷款经纪人，他自己的收入已经减半，这强迫他采取了一种禅宗的态度。
Jon has run some numbers to try to understand exactly what happened with the developer of this building, a small-time operator who moved to Chicago from Bosnia back in 1994, named Haso Meseljevic, who's currently unreachable, at least by us or anybody in 1633 Farwell. Though more about that in a bit.
乔恩算了一些数字，试图弄清楚这栋楼的开发商到底发生了什么。这是一个1994年从波斯尼亚搬到芝加哥的小经营者，名叫哈索·梅塞尔耶维奇，目前无法联系上，至少我们或法尔韦尔街1633号的任何人无法联系上。尽管稍后会有更多关于他的内容。
Public records show that Meseljevic and his son took out a loan of $5.1 million to buy and rehab this building, and that by 2007, he still owed $2.9 million to the bank for the unsold units. Which means, Jon calculates, that Meseljevic was paying the bank at least $20,000 a month on that debt.
公共记录显示，梅塞尔耶维奇和他的儿子贷款510万美元购买并修复了这栋建筑，到2007年，他仍欠银行290万美元未售出单元的贷款。这意味着，乔恩计算出，梅塞尔耶维奇每月至少要向银行支付20,000美元的债务。
So, back in October 2007, Jon bought the last unit sold in this building, right as the market was turning.
所以，早在2007年10月，就在市场转向时，乔恩买下了这栋楼里售出的最后一个单元。
But then right after I closed, November, December, January rolled by, and I don't think he closed any units within those three months. And I more or less would guess that's what put him under.
但就在我成交后，11月、12月、1月过去了，我不认为他在那三个月内成交了任何单元。我或多或少会猜这就是让他破产的原因。
You know, when you're trying to carry a $20,000 expense month-to-month and you're not a very well-known, highly capitalized developer like some of these guys are, it's just not having a sale in three or four months is enough to put you under. So that's essentially my guess as to what happened.
你知道，当你试图每月承担20,000美元的开支，而你又不像那些家伙那样是一个非常有名、资本雄厚的开发商时，三四个月没有销售额足以让你破产。所以这本质上是我对所发生事情的猜测。
Even before the housing crisis and the recession, residents say this is a developer who seemed to cut corners and do the bare minimum. His business seemed perpetually strapped for cash, even though he and his family drove around in a yellow Hummer. And this right here is where the ugliness of the recessions intersects with the normal, everyday seediness of a lot of real estate development in a particularly toxic way.
甚至在住房危机和经济衰退之前，居民们说这位开发商似乎总是偷工减料，只做最基本的事情。他的生意似乎总是资金紧张，尽管他和他的家人开着一辆黄色悍马到处跑。而就在这里，经济衰退的丑陋与许多房地产开发中日常的肮脏以一种特别有毒的方式交织在一起。
Residents had all kinds of problems they couldn't get him to fix, problems that go way, way beyond the normal kinds of final details you need a builder to repair when you move into a place.
居民们有各种各样他们无法让他修复的问题，这些问题远远超出了你搬进一个地方时需要建筑商修复的正常最后细节。
Shortly after staying here, we started seeing things like this column here separated from the ceiling and collapsed into the ground.
刚住进来不久，我们就开始看到像这根柱子与天花板分离并塌向地面的事情。
Jen and Peter Benedetto have a ground-floor unit that is jammed with musical gear and DJ equipment and the stuff that he uses to publish a quarterly journal of goth art. They show me how the floor is sinking away from the walls and the walls are separating from the ceiling of the unit, because there's nothing underneath the thin floor boards. There's no concrete slab, just dirt.
詹和彼得·贝内代托的底层单元挤满了音乐设备和DJ器材，以及他用来出版一份哥特艺术季刊的东西。他们向我展示地板是如何从墙壁上沉降的，墙壁是如何从天花板上分离的，因为薄地板下面什么都没有。没有混凝土板，只有泥土。
Right here is one of the worst spots, where the walls are separating from the ceiling. And it changes daily. You can see it getting worse every single day.
就在这里，是最糟糕的地方之一，墙壁正在从天花板上分离。而且它每天都在变。你可以看到它每天都在恶化。
Also when they moved in, the whole condo smelled like sewage. When they would drain the bathtub, little bubbles of sewage gas would come up in the toilet. At first, the developer told them that he had no money to fix this. He told him that he was using all of the money that they had paid for their condo to rehab the other units in the building.
此外，当他们搬进来时，整个公寓闻起来像污水。当他们排掉浴缸的水时，小气泡的污水味会从马桶里冒出来。起初，开发商告诉他们他没钱修理这个。他告诉他，他正在用他们支付给公寓的钱来翻新楼里的其他单元。
But then Jen and Peter but a big handmade sign in the window facing the street, saying that their apartment smelled like sewage and the developer wouldn't fix it, which is the kind of thing that could keep somebody from buying a condo unit in the building, so the developer decided to send out some relatives to fix this.
但后来詹和彼得在面向街道的窗户上贴了一个大的手写牌子，说他们的公寓闻起来像污水，开发商不修，这可能会阻止某人购买这栋楼的公寓单元，所以开发商决定派一些亲戚来修理。
First of all, they come in and they say, well, you're going to have to show us how these bubbles come up the toilet. So I fill up the bathtub and I pull the plug out, and the minute I let the water out, he's like, nothing's happening, nothing's happening. And he's getting all excited that he's disproving us. And then I'm like, just give it a second.
首先，他们进来后说，好吧，你需要给我们展示这些气泡是怎么从马桶里冒出来的。所以我给浴缸注满水，拔掉塞子，我放水的瞬间，他说，什么也没发生，什么也没发生。他因为反驳了我们而感到非常兴奋。然后我说，等一下。
And then, sure enough, the bubbles start coming up. And then he starts laughing. He calls his friend, come look at this. And he's all excited and happy. And I'm like, what's so funny? He's like, I've never seen this before.
然后，果然，气泡开始冒出来了。然后他开始笑。他叫他的朋友，过来看这个。他非常兴奋和高兴。我问，有什么好笑的？他说，我以前从没见过这个。
So then they take the toilet off, and then the guy that he called in starts laughing again. And I'm like, you guys, what's so funny? And he's like, oh, you bought a place without even concrete under the floor. They gave you dirt. Ha, ha, ha.
于是他们拆下马桶，他叫来的那个人又开始笑。我说，你们，有什么好笑的？他说，哦，你买的房子连地板下面都没铺混凝土。他们给了你泥土。哈哈哈。
Ho, ho.
呵呵。
I never would have bought this place.
我绝不会买这个地方。
Dirt, dirt, you live on dirt. Ho, ho, ho, ho.
泥土，泥土，你住在泥土上。呵呵呵呵。
So there's not even concrete under our floor, which is why we're sinking in like that.
所以我们的地板下面甚至没有混凝土，这就是为什么我们正在那样下沉。
It's loose dirt. It's not even packed.
是松散的泥土。甚至没压实。
We also had, because of the sewage backup we had maggots, fly eggs in the sewage. And in the spring, we have flies procreating in our plumbing and inhabiting our--
我们还有，因为污水倒灌，我们有了蛆，污水里的苍蝇卵。春天的时候，有苍蝇在我们的管道里繁殖并占据我们的——
Yeah, I've never seen so many flies. We had fly traps up and they were just covered in flies. It was really nasty.
是的，我从来没见过这么多苍蝇。我们放了苍蝇拍，上面满是苍蝇。真的很恶心。
Hundreds, hundreds of dead flies hanging on fly tape in our bathroom.
几百只，几百只死苍蝇挂在浴室的蝇纸上。
Remember, this is a condo building with granite countertops and brand new hardwood floors. But Jen and Peter say that, underneath the surface, everything's fake. When they brought out an independent plumber about the sewage smell, this plumber informed them that the entire building's plumbing needed to be redone.
记住，这是一栋拥有花岗岩台面和全新硬木地板的公寓楼。但詹和彼得说，在表面之下，一切都是假的。当他们请了一位独立水管工来处理污水气味时，这位水管工告诉他们，整栋楼的管道都需要重做。
Part of the problem is that so much building and condo conversion was going on during the boom that the city of Chicago did not have enough inspectors to keep up. And two residents in this building told me stories about the developer making cosmetic changes the day the inspector finally did show up and then ripping out the changes once he left.
部分问题在于，繁荣时期进行了太多的建筑和公寓改建，以至于芝加哥市没有足够的检查员来跟上。这栋楼里的两位居民给我讲了开发商在检查员终于出现的那天进行装饰性改变，然后在他离开后拆除这些改变的故事。
And in the months after they moved in, residents went to the developer with a list of pretty urgent repairs, but by the spring of 2008, the developer stopped returning their phone calls. Then things deteriorated further.
在他们搬进来后的几个月里，居民们拿着一份非常紧急的维修清单去找开发商，但到了2008年春天，开发商就不再回他们的电话了。然后情况进一步恶化。
In June, the electric company posted notices that the power was going to be shut off because of the developer's nonpayment of bills, then the water company did the same, then the garbage collection service. The insurance coverage for the building lapsed in July. And none of this, I learned, is unusual.
6月，电力公司张贴通知，因为开发商未付款，电将被切断，然后自来水公司也做了同样的事情，然后是垃圾收集服务。楼里的保险在7月到期。而且据我所知，这一切都不罕见。
So this-- do you want me to start? OK. So this is a foreclosure. Boarded-up windows, boarded-up basement, boarded-up front door, empty, like, get it, foreclosure. So here's another one. It's a two-flat. And here's another one. This is a for-sale-by-owner going into foreclosure.
所以这——你想让我开始吗？好的。所以这是一个止赎。木板封住的窗户，木板封住的地下室，木板封住的前门，空的，懂吗，止赎。这里还有另一个。这是一个两层的公寓。这里还有另一个。这是一个正在进入止赎程序的业主自售房屋。
Brian White, the executive director of a community group that deals with housing issues, called Lakeside Community Development Corporation, takes me on a driving tour of the neighborhood. Before the housing bubble, Rogers Park was 80% renters, a shabby neighborhood where students and seniors and young families could get an affordable place.
布莱恩·怀特，一个处理住房问题的社区组织“湖畔社区发展公司”的执行董事，带我开车参观了这个社区。在住房泡沫之前，罗杰斯公园80%是租户，一个破旧的社区，学生、老年人和年轻家庭可以在那里找到负担得起的地方。
Then developers threw a lot of money in, hoping that it would be the next gentrified neighborhood of Chicago's north side. A survey that Brian's group did back in 2006 showed that 15% of the housing stock, about 1,000 units, were being turned into condos, all at the same time. And it didn't work, partly because the developers were building for higher income people who simply did not want to move to corners like this one, at Touhy and Rogers.
然后开发商投入了大量资金，希望它能成为芝加哥北侧下一个高档社区。布莱恩的组织在2006年做的一项调查显示，15%的住房存量，大约1000个单元，正在同时被改造成公寓。这并没有奏效，部分原因是开发商是为那些根本不想搬到图希和罗杰斯这样的角落的高收入人群建造的。
So, this building that we're looking at right here, this is a project that's been sitting empty for three years. It was advertised as an 18-unit unit luxury condo property.
所以，我们现在看到的这栋建筑，这是一个已经空置了三年的项目。它被宣传为18个单元的豪华公寓物业。
I noticed the air quotes around the word luxury.
我注意到了“豪华”这个词周围的引号。
Well, I mean, this is what I was going to say is one of the challenges. Right across the street from this building is another building. Seven of the nine units are in foreclosure. Directly next to that is a garage where they park ice cream trucks. It's a very beat-up building. Merely down the block from that are some two-flats that are pretty old.
好吧，我的意思是，这就是我刚才要说的挑战之一。在这栋楼的街对面是另一栋楼。九个单元中有七个处于止赎状态。紧挨着它的是一个停放冰淇淋车的车库。这是一栋非常破旧的建筑。离那仅一个街区的地方是一些非常古老的两层公寓。
If you're a consumer who has a luxury dollar to spend, chances are you're not going to be spending it at this particular intersection. And so, there's just a pattern of developers coming in and buying up buildings and all trying to market them as these luxury developments in a neighborhood that really is not a luxury neighborhood, and the building has failed. And now it's just--
如果你是一个有钱去消费豪华产品的消费者，很有可能你不会在这个特定的十字路口消费。所以，只是有一种模式，开发商进来购买建筑，并试图将它们作为这些豪华开发项目推销，在一个真正不是豪华社区的社区里，而且这栋楼失败了。现在它只是——
Boarded up on the ground floor.
一楼被木板封住了。
Boarded up on the ground floor, broken windows, a little bit of graffiti. And it's not--
一楼被木板封住了，碎了的窗户，一点点涂鸦。而且它不是——
The city of Chicago and groups like Brian's tried to convince developers to include some moderately priced units in the mix. And there were government subsidies available to help them do that. But Brian says, understandably, people wanted to make a killing.
芝加哥市和像布莱恩这样的组织试图说服开发商在组合中包括一些中等价位的单元。并且有政府补贴可以帮助他们这样做。但布莱恩说，可以理解，人们想赚大钱。
Some had taken the money out of the stock market and put it into real estate during the boom, figuring that it was going to be more lucrative. And as a result, every block or two in Rogers Park today, we drive by uninhabited or barely habited buildings, with signs advertising brand new condos with depressingly similar lists of super deluxe amenities. Yes, granite counters, stainless steel appliances.
有些人把钱从股市中取出，在繁荣时期投入到房地产中，认为它会更有利可图。结果，今天在罗杰斯公园的每一个或两个街区，我们开车经过无人居住或几乎无人居住的建筑，上面挂着广告，宣传着带有令人沮丧的相似的超级豪华设施清单的全新公寓。是的，花岗岩台面，不锈钢电器。
But it's the sexy on the outside, crappy on the inside kind of rehab work that also the associations are now struggling with. They bought for the granite countertops and the stainless steel. Nobody bothered to check and see if the wiring and the plumbing was done properly, or if the foundation was intact. But that's pretty common.
但这也是那种外表性感、内部糟糕的翻修工程，协会现在也正在为此挣扎。他们买了花岗岩台面和不锈钢产品。没有人费心检查线路和管道是否做得合适，或者地基是否完好。但这很常见。
At the corner of Seeley and Birchwood, the sign advertises all the usual amenities, plus one more, a 42-inch plasma TV with each unit.
在西利和伯奇伍德的拐角处，招牌宣传着所有通常的设施，外加一个，每个单元配一台42英寸等离子电视。
I don't know. One of the things I've seen here as I walk around the neighborhood at nighttime, you can sometimes see when buildings-- you see the foreclosed buildings or the struggling buildings, because you'll have, like, a building where half the building is completely dark. And then there'll be, like, one unit where the light's on and there's a big plasma screen TV. And that's kind of the symbol of the lonely person. He's got his plasma screen TV. He has no neighbors, but he's got his plasma screen, and he's there.
我不知道。我在这里晚上走动时看到的一件事是，你有时可以看到建筑——你可以看到止赎的建筑或挣扎的建筑，因为你会有一个，比如，一栋楼，半栋楼完全是黑的。然后会有一个，比如，一个单元，灯亮着，有一台大等离子电视。那就是孤独者的象征。他有等离子电视。他没有邻居，但他有等离子电视，他就待在那里。
But what difference does it make if I'm living in this building and I've got no neighbors and I'm just going to have to wait three or four years before anybody else moves in?
但如果我住在这栋楼里，没有邻居，我得等三四年才会有人搬进来，这有什么区别呢？
You're going to be dealing with things like frozen water pipes. You're going to be dealing with things like mold from moisture. If there's heat left on and there's moisture in the apartment, it will start to spread mold. You're going to be dealing with things like vermin.
你要处理像冻裂水管这样的事情。你要处理像潮湿产生的霉菌这样的事情。如果留着暖气且公寓里有湿气，它就会开始滋生霉菌。你要处理像害虫这样的事情。
And then the other one, and the biggest one, is the difficulty raising the kind of cash to pay the water bill, the gas bill, the insurance costs, pay for the garbage to be hauled away. If there's no money coming in, you can't sustain those costs.
另一个，最大的一个是，筹集现金支付水费、煤气费、保险费、支付垃圾清运费的困难。如果没有收入，你就无法维持这些成本。
And we have buildings now where you've got an individual unit owner who's paid the water bill, for example. Well, water bill on one building we were dealing with on the south side, she had a $3,000 water bill that she had to pay out of her own pocket to keep the water on, because there were no other unit owners to pay assessments to pay the water bill.
我们现在有一些建筑，比如有一个个人业主支付了水费。好吧，我们在南区处理的一栋楼，她不得不自掏腰包支付3000美元的水费来维持供水，因为没有其他业主支付分摊费用来缴纳水费。
Wait, it was one person in a building with how much water? How many units?
等等，是一个人住在一栋有多少水的楼里？有多少个单元？
She had a eight-unit building. The other units were all in foreclosure, and the developer had never paid the water bill. So she was stuck paying the water bill for the entire building.
她住的是一栋八单元的建筑。其他单元都处于止赎状态，而开发商从未支付过水费。所以她被迫为整栋楼支付水费。
And in fact, most of that is starting to happen at 1633 W. Farwell. There's nobody to fix the building's roof, which they'd been told was brand-new when they moved in, but which leaks, ruining drywall in some units. One estimate put the repair job at $56,000. There's no money to redo the building's plumbing. There's no money to put in a buzzer and intercom system, or to pay the liens on the building from contractors who were never paid. Those liens total at least $175,000.
事实上，大部分情况开始发生在法尔韦尔西街1633号。没有人修理楼里的屋顶，当他们搬进来时被告知是全新的，但它漏水，毁坏了一些单元的干墙。一份估价显示维修费用为56,000美元。没有钱重做楼里的管道。没有钱安装蜂鸣器和对讲系统，或者支付那些未获报酬的承包商对这栋楼的留置权。这些留置权总额至少为175,000美元。
Because this is a condo building, the way it's supposed to work is that all the condo owners pay each month into a maintenance and repair fund. But there's a catch. In Illinois, until 75% of the units are sold, that fund is controlled by the developer, the guy who disappeared. In this case, supposedly back to Bosnia. And all that money seems to be gone, too.
因为这是一栋公寓楼，它的运作方式应该是所有公寓业主每月缴纳维护和修理基金。但有一个陷阱。在伊利诺伊州，直到75%的单元售出之前，该基金由开发商控制，那个消失的家伙。在这种情况下，据称回到了波斯尼亚。而且所有的钱似乎也都不见了。
Brian says this is not unusual. It is so not unusual that a move is underway to change the laws to make it easier for condo owners to control that money. Brian's take on all this, by the way, is very different from the real estate guy who lives at 1633 Farwell, Jon Miller. Brian says that lots of developers have vanished.
布莱恩说这并不罕见。这太不罕见了，以至于正在采取行动修改法律，使公寓业主更容易控制这笔钱。顺便说一句，布莱恩对此事的看法与住在法尔韦尔西街1633号的房地产人乔恩·米勒截然不同。布莱恩说很多开发商都消失了。
Well, some of them are still around, but a lot of them have disappeared.
嗯，他们中有些人还在，但很多人已经消失了。
And when people have fled, are you thinking that they fled and they're bankrupt and they've got nothing, or they fled and they're walking away with huge piles of money and defaulting on their buildings and just hoping nobody catches them?
当人们逃跑时，你认为他们逃跑是因为破产了，一无所有，还是他们逃跑是因为带着巨额资金走了，对建筑违约，只是希望没人抓住他们？
The latter. They walked away with big piles of money. We have people who bought properties with mortgages, took cash out from the mortgage by refinancing, or in some cases, took cash out at closing, and then went and bought property in other countries, where they are now wealthy people in those countries because they've left these foreclosures here.
后者。他们带着巨额资金走了。我们有通过抵押贷款购买房产的人，通过再融资从抵押贷款中套取现金，或者在某些情况下，在成交时套取现金，然后去其他国家购买房产，现在他们在那些国家成了有钱人，因为他们留下了这些止赎的烂摊子。
I tried to get the developer-- again, his name is Haso Meseljevic-- to come on the air and tell his side of the story. He never answered at the phone number listed for him. His son, Samel Meseljevic, who was his business partner in developing this particular building, is the one who said in a quick phone conversation that his father has moved back to Bosnia.
我试图让开发商——再说一次，他的名字是哈索·梅塞尔耶维奇——上节目说出他的故事。他从来没有接听为他列出的电话号码。他的儿子萨梅尔·梅塞尔耶维奇，他是开发这栋楼的商业伙伴，在一次简短的电话交谈中说他的父亲已经搬回波斯尼亚了。
I repeatedly tried to get Samel to agree to a real conversation about what happened on tape. He invited me to his house, gave me his address, and then didn't show up. When I tried to reschedule, he insisted that the next morning he was going to be going out of the country for a week, though he didn't seem to leave Chicago. And I say that because he picked up his phone the next afternoon when I called.
我多次试图让萨梅尔同意进行一次关于所发生事情的正式谈话。他邀请我去他家，给了我地址，然后没有出现。当我试图重新安排时，他坚持说第二天早上他要出国一周，尽管他似乎并没有离开芝加哥。我这么说是因为我第二天下午打电话时他接了电话。
One time that I raised the possibility of an interview, Samel simply hung up on me. The lawyer working for him and his dad, whose name is Hugh Howard, and who has a downtown office in Chicago on Monroe Street, didn't return calls. And once, when somebody in his office accidentally picked up the phone when I called and identified myself, that person hung up on me as well.
有一次我提出采访的可能性时，萨梅尔直接挂断了我的电话。为他和他的父亲工作的律师，名字叫休·霍华德，在芝加哥门罗街有办公室，没有回电话。有一次，当他办公室里的人偶然接起电话，而我自报家门时，那个人也挂断了我的电话。
All right, we are all here, so there are St. Patty's Day beers in the fridge and cupcakes for later.
好了，我们都到了，冰箱里有圣帕特里克节的啤酒，晚点还有纸杯蛋糕。
In a top-floor apartment, the five elected officers of the condo association, and a black-and-white cat named Checkers, are at the condo association's regular meeting. If this meeting is typical, I think it is safe to say that a year of trying to fix all the problems in this half-empty building is taking some very nice, very responsible people, and driving them all slowly crazy.
在一间顶楼公寓里，公寓协会的五名当选官员，还有一只名叫跳棋的黑白猫，正在举行公寓协会的例会。如果这次会议是典型的，我想可以肯定地说，尝试修复这栋半空建筑中所有问题的一年时间，正在把一些非常好、非常有责任心的人逼得慢慢发疯。
They are in an impossible legal limbo. The bank was scheduled to finally foreclose on the developer's 19 units in March, and then the bank pushed it to April. And they'll probably push it back again and again. Banks don't want to take these properties onto their books, and they put it off as long as possible.
他们陷入了一种不可能的法律困境。银行原定于3月最终对开发商的19个单元进行止赎，然后银行推迟到了4月。他们可能会一次又一次地推迟。银行不想把这些物业记入账面，他们尽可能地推迟。
And it is only when the bank finally does foreclose that, from a legal perspective, these units will finally have an owner. The owner will be the bank, and the building will be 100% sold, which means that this group will finally be a real condo association and will finally have the power to address their problems in the way that any normal condo association does.
只有当银行最终止赎时，从法律角度来看，这些单元才会有真正的主人。主人将是银行，建筑将100%售出，这意味着这群人最终将成为一个真正的公寓协会，并最终有权像任何正常的公寓协会那样解决他们的问题。
They can make residents pay monthly fees and use those fees to do maintenance and repairs. And then the issue for them will be, will the bank, as owner of 19 units, kick in its share of the maintenance and repair fees like all the other owners? Often it doesn't.
他们可以要求居民支付月费，并利用这些费用进行维护和修理。然后他们的问题将是，银行作为19个单元的所有者，会像其他业主一样分摊维护和修理费吗？通常它不会。
As you might imagine, the repairs, the legal complications, the money problems, the meetings, the worry of owning property in a half-empty building that is deteriorating and not insured, has taken its toll on everybody here, stressed them out. Of course, they could walk away.
如你所料，维修、法律纠纷、资金问题、会议、拥有半空建筑的担忧，这些都在恶化且没有保险，对这里的每个人造成了影响，让他们压力重重。当然，他们可以走开。
Jen and Peter, the couple with the sewage smell and the sinking floor, pay exactly the same to live here that they used to pay in rent, $1,100 a month. If they defaulted on their mortgage and moved out now, all they would lose is the $3,000 down that they paid back when they bought. Jen would have bad credit for seven years, since her name is on the mortgage, but Peter wouldn't.
詹和彼得，那对有污水气味和下沉地板的夫妇，住在这里支付的费用和他们过去租房时一样，每月1100美元。如果他们现在违约抵押贷款搬走，他们只会损失买房时支付的3000美元首付。詹会有七年的不良信用记录，因为她的名字在贷款上，但彼得不会。
But for now, they're staying put. They've all been organizing and fighting for over a year now, and it's sort of become their identity. They see themselves as the responsible ones. In a world of irresponsible developers and bankers, they're the people who won't renege on their obligations. It's now a point of pride.
但目前，他们留下来了。他们组织起来并抗争了一年多了，这已经成了他们身份的一部分。他们视自己为负责任的人。在一个充满不负责任的开发商和银行家的世界里，他们是那些不会违背义务的人。这现在成了一种骄傲。
Karen Webber lives in a top-floor unit.
卡伦·韦伯住在一个顶楼单元。
To me it's a very black-and-white situation, because I signed a contract, I have an ability to pay, and as long as there are blood in my veins I will do my part to honor my word.
对我来说，这是一个非常非黑即白的情况，因为我签了合同，我有能力支付，只要我血管里还有血，我就会尽我所能信守诺言。
On the other hand, Maria Hadden, who runs the condo association, says she sometimes wonders if it really matters if she defaults. So she'd lose maybe $10,000 that she's put into her place, have bad credit for seven years. She could stop paying her mortgage for a few months, save up her cash, and then when she got kicked out, rent a nice place, cheap.
另一方面，管理公寓协会的玛丽亚·哈登说，她有时想知道违约是否真的有关系。所以她会损失她投入到房子里的10000美元左右，有七年的不良信用记录。她可以停止支付抵押贷款几个月，存下现金，然后在被赶走时，在附近租一个便宜又漂亮的地方。
Does it matter to you, your credit score?
你的信用评分对你来说有关系吗？
No.
没有。
So you could basically be out of here, wash your hands of this. Instead of paying $1,800-something a month, you could be paying, like, $1,000 and have an incredibly beautiful apartment somewhere nearby.
所以你基本上可以离开这里，洗手不干了。与其每月支付1800多美元，你可能只需支付1000美元左右，在附近拥有一个令人难以置信的美丽公寓。
Uh-huh, yeah. That's true.
嗯，是的。那是真的。
So it doesn't really-- I don't understand how it makes so much sense to stay.
所以它真的——我不明白留下来有什么意义。
What would happen if everybody left?
如果大家都走了会发生什么？
Then you all would be happier.
那你们大家会更开心。
If I leave and foreclose, and then Jon leaves, and Jim and Rick leave, then the people that are left are left even more up a creek than they were before.
如果我离开并止赎，然后乔恩离开，吉姆和里克也离开，那么剩下的人比以前更陷入困境。
Right, then they're carrying the cost of the roof and they're carrying the cost of the buzzer system.
对，那么他们得承担屋顶的费用，还得承担蜂鸣器系统的费用。
Yeah, it becomes impossible. It's kind of like we're in this together. We're all going to do this or we're not going to do this at all, because it's not going to work unless we all do it. So it's kind of like staying here.
是的，这变得不可能了。这有点像我们是在一起的。我们要么一起做这件事，要么根本不做，因为它如果不一起做是行不通的。所以这有点像留在这里。
Lately, the developer's family has tried to move some renters into the vacant units, to raise a little money, possibly to stall the bank from foreclosing. True to form, one woman moved here from England in the middle of a Chicago winter to find her unit had no heat or hot water. Another renter, somebody on a Section 8 public housing voucher, was put into a unit which didn't even have a toilet.
最近，开发商的家人试图把一些租户搬进空置的单元，以筹集一点钱，可能是为了阻止银行止赎。正如预料的那样，一个女人在芝加哥严冬中从英国搬到这里，发现她的单元没有暖气或热水。另一个租户，一个拿着第8条公共住房券的人，被安置进了一个甚至没有马桶的单元。
Coming up, real-life secret agents who work for the government and are out on the front lines to save our economy. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，为政府工作的现实生活中的特工，他们处于拯救我们经济的前线。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, scenes from the recession. We've arrived at act two of our show.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，经济衰退的场景。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。
Act two, Unbreaking the Bank.
第二幕，拯救银行。
In an office park in Irvine, California, in a conference room with fluorescent lights, wheelie chairs, a whiteboard, something totally unrecession-like is taking place, new employee orientation.
在加利福尼亚州欧文市的一个办公园区，在一个带有荧光灯、带轮椅子、白板的会议室里，正在发生一些完全不像经济衰退的事情，新员工入职培训。
OK, can I get everybody's attention again, please?
好了，我能再请大家注意一下吗？
32 new employees arranged in three long rows. These are the FDIC's newest recruits. The FDIC, the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation, not only insures the money that you and I keep in the bank, it's also the agency that closes down banks when they fail.
32名新员工排成三排。这些是联邦存款保险公司（FDIC）的最新招募人员。FDIC，联邦存款保险公司，不仅为你我存在银行里的钱提供保险，它也是在银行倒闭时将其关闭的机构。
Since banks fail almost every weekend now-- yes, a bank fails every weekend; and in fact, most weekends, lately it's two banks-- the FDIC needs help. These people here are only 32 of 600 people the agency is hiring for this regional office, 600 new agents to train about bank failures, 600 new computer accounts.
由于现在几乎每个周末都有银行倒闭——是的，每个周末都有银行倒闭；事实上，最近大多数周末是两家银行——FDIC需要帮助。这里的人只是该机构为这个地区办公室招聘的600人中的32人，600名关于银行倒闭的新培训特工，600个新电脑账户。
Log in, and then on the left-hand side, type in no fear and hit ENTER.
登录，然后在左侧输入“无畏”，按回车键。
Got that? No fear, then ENTER. The FDIC's mission is to ensure stability in the banking system. What that means, actually, when a bank fails, is something pretty dramatic. The government rolls in unannounced, shuts the bank down, and takes it over as a way to protect our deposits. The whole thing is planned like a SWAT team, if SWAT teams had accountants in them.
懂了吗？无畏，然后回车。FDIC的使命是确保银行系统的稳定。这实际上意味着，当一家银行倒闭时，会发生相当戏剧性的事情。政府会不速而至，关闭银行，并接管它，作为保护我们存款的一种方式。整个事情计划得就像一个特警队，如果特警队里有会计的话。
And then reason that they do it this way is that if the public found out that the bank was failing before the government actually stepped in, people might pull their deposits out and cause a run on the bank. Also, if the people working at the bank knew that the government was going to be seizing the bank, they might steal, they might destroy paperwork.
他们这样做的原因是，如果公众在政府真正介入之前发现银行要倒闭，人们可能会提取存款并导致挤兑。此外，如果银行里的员工知道政府要查封银行，他们可能会偷窃，可能会销毁文件。
The government believes that this is the best way to protect depositors, you and me. This is Tom Murray, one of the FDIC bosses here.
政府认为这是保护储户，即你和我，的最佳方式。这是汤姆·默里，这里FDIC的老板之一。
So, some of you may go to a bank closing this weekend. Don't tell your significant other where you're going or what you're doing. Don't talk in a conversation that can be overheard. Don't check in at the hotel and say, oh, well, I'm here for this event. You are on a secret mission.
所以，你们中的一些人这个周末可能会去银行关闭现场。不要告诉你的重要他人你要去哪里或做什么。不要在会被人听到的对话中谈论。不要在酒店登记入住时说，哦，我来这里是为了这个活动。你们是在执行秘密任务。
Today we take you on that secret mission, when the FDIC takes over. Chana Jaffe-Walt talked to all kinds of people involved in one bank failure, a place called the Bank of Clark County in southwest Washington State.
今天我们带你去执行那个秘密任务，当FDIC接管时。查娜·贾菲-沃尔特与所有参与一家银行倒闭事件的人进行了交谈，该银行位于华盛顿州西南部的克拉克县银行。
Long before most of the Bank of Clark County employees knew their bank was dead, the FDIC was planning its demise. They'd been having meetings, contacting other banks in the region, trying to find one that would take over the Bank of Clark County's assets after it failed. All of these negotiations were top secret.
在大多数克拉克县银行员工知道他们的银行已死之前，FDIC就在计划它的终结。他们一直在开会，联系该地区的其他银行，试图找到一家愿意在克拉克县银行倒闭后接管其资产的银行。所有这些谈判都是绝密的。
And then the time came. Thursday, January 15, 2009, the operation begins. 80 FDIC agents pull into Vancouver, Washington. Their rental cars are generic. Their arrival times staggered. One by one, the agents check into the hotel, each quietly offering a fake name to the guy at the desk.
然后时间到了。2009年1月15日，星期四，行动开始。80名FDIC特工抵达华盛顿州温哥华。他们的租赁车很普通。他们的到达时间错开了。特工们一个接一个地住进酒店，每个人都悄悄地向柜台的人报了一个假名。
9:00 PM, the FDIC calls the CEO of another bank nearby, Umpqua Bank. Your bank, they tell him, has been selected to take over the Bank of Clark County. You can't tell anyone. Come to a meeting tomorrow at noon. The FDIC will tell you everything you need to know.
晚上9点，FDIC致电附近另一家银行，安普夸银行的首席执行官。他们告诉他，你的银行已被选中接管克拉克县银行。你不能告诉任何人。明天中午来参加会议。FDIC会告诉你所有你需要知道的事情。
And so, Friday morning, the Bank of Clark County employees get up, go to work, turn on the lights and go about their day. And Ric Carey, a vice president from Umpqua Bank, sits down with the FDIC and begins to plan.
所以，周五早上，克拉克县银行的员工起床，去上班，打开灯，继续他们的一天。安普夸银行的副总裁里克·凯里与FDIC坐下来开始计划。
We actually met with the FDIC beginning at about 12:30 on Friday, and they were in a hotel, under a different name. We made sure that there was no one from outside of our two organizations there.
我们实际上是在周五大约12:30开始与FDIC会面的，他们是在一家酒店里，用的是不同的名字。我们确保那里没有我们两个组织之外的人。
Does it feel like a spy movie?
这感觉像间谍电影吗？
It almost does. They know what they're doing. They've done this before. Quite a production.
几乎是。他们知道自己在做什么。他们以前做过这个。相当大的制作。
My name is Todd Zalk, Bank of Clark County, the best community business bank, because we've changed the game in business banking. And we were winning. Often, when I would go to a networking meeting or event, I would introduce myself that way.
我叫托德·扎尔克，克拉克县银行，最好的社区商业银行，因为我们改变了商业银行业的游戏规则。而且我们正在赢。通常，当我去参加社交会议或活动时，我会那样介绍自己。
Todd Zalk is what you call a team player, total bank loyalist to the end, beyond the end. Four weeks after the failure, Todd's still wearing his Bank of Clark County name tag. still passing out his bank business cards, always with a warm handshake, constant eye contact, inserting your name whenever possible.
托德·扎尔克是你所说的团队合作者，对银行忠诚到底，甚至超越了终点。银行倒闭四周后，托德仍然戴着克拉克县银行的名牌，仍然在发放他的银行名片，总是带着热情的握手，持续的眼神交流，尽可能地插入你的名字。
Friday, as Ric Carey snuck into the nondescript FDIC secret location, Todd was playing for the team.
周五，当里克·凯里溜进FDIC不显眼的秘密地点时，托德正在为团队效力。
Most of the day I had spent out meeting with businesses. I had a couple networking events, and then I came back to the bank, and--
大部分时间我都在外面与企业会面。我有几次社交活动，然后我回到银行，而且——
Wait, so you were still bringing business in that Friday.
等等，所以那个周五你还在拉业务。
I actually was. I had people that wanted to open accounts. In fact, Chana, in the fourth quarter, I opened over 55 accounts for Bank of Clark County.
我确实在。我有想开户的人。事实上，查娜，在第四季度，我为克拉克县银行开设了55个以上的账户。
Todd and his coworkers had no idea the bank was about to be taken over. He knew they were going through a rough time. Just last week the CEO had called a staff meeting about it. But the CEO was clear. Things were under control.
托德和他的同事们不知道银行即将被接管。他知道他们正经历一段艰难时期。就在上周，首席执行官还为此召开了一次员工会议。但首席执行官说得很清楚。一切都在控制之中。
He used this analogy that we were the ship, and we've gone through a storm and that we were a little bit tattered, but we were still weathering it well, and that we maybe were taking on a little bit of water. And we were looking for someone to maybe buy the bank, and had a few buyers that were very interested. And within the next 60 days, we should know who the new face of the bank would be. So that's what I had thought.
他用了这个类比，我们是一艘船，我们经历了一场风暴，我们有点破损，但我们仍然很好地经受住了它，我们可能正在进一点水。我们正在寻找某人可能购买这家银行，并且有几位买家非常感兴趣。在接下来的60天内，我们应该知道谁会是银行的新面孔。所以我就是这么想的。
Many, many Bank of Clark County employees told me about the ship meeting. Mostly it made sense to them. The CEO said they were doing OK, they were doing OK. But in fact, things had been changing at the bank since 2005. That's when they went big into commercial and real estate loans.
许多，许多克拉克县银行的员工告诉我关于那次“船”会议的事情。对他们来说大部分说得通。首席执行官说他们做得还可以，他们做得还可以。但事实上，自2005年以来，银行的情况一直在改变。那是他们大规模进入商业和房地产贷款的时候。
They were a young bank. They felt they had to be aggressive. And sometimes that meant making loans other banks wouldn't have made, loans that ended up killing them. Washington State regulators audit every bank several times a year, and they noted the Bank of Clark County's declining health.
他们是一家年轻的银行。他们觉得必须咄咄逼人。有时这意味着发放其他银行不会发放的贷款，那些最终害死他们的贷款。华盛顿州监管机构每年审计每家银行几次，他们注意到了克拉克县银行健康的下降。
Its capital reserves were getting low, so low the bank was in danger of not being able to cover its debts and obligations. And then, you know the story, housing prices dropped, developers couldn't make payments. The story finally ends Friday, January 16, 5:01 PM.
它的资本储备越来越低，低到银行面临无法偿还债务和义务的危险。然后，你知道这个故事，房价下跌，开发商无法支付款项。故事终于在1月16日，星期五，下午5:01结束。
Two FDIC agents and a Washington State regulator enter the Bank of Clark County. Casual, head straight for the CEO's office. There, behind closed doors, they deliver the news. They tell him his bank is under-capitalized. It has failed.
两名FDIC特工和一名华盛顿州监管人员进入克拉克县银行。随意地，直接走向首席执行官办公室。在那里，闭门谢客，他们传达了这个消息。他们告诉他他的银行资本不足。它已经倒闭了。
5:03 PM, an agent positioned by the CEO's office door types this news into a BlackBerry. It's received by everyone on the FDIC takeover team. 5:05 PM, FDIC agents begin closing in on the bank. A few are already inside, quietly and discreetly securing the cash in the vaults.
下午5:03，一名站在首席执行官办公室门外的特工在黑莓手机上输入了这个消息。FDIC接管团队的每个人都收到了。下午5:05，FDIC特工开始包围银行。一些人已经进入，悄悄地、谨慎地确保金库里的现金安全。
Todd Zalk, oblivious to all this, heads back into the office after a long day of work.
对这一切一无所知的托德·扎尔克在漫长的一天工作后回到办公室。
I could tell that the mood at the bank seemed odd. And I thought, well, hmmm, I wonder if they found a buyer, and kind of people have heard, because I was gone most of the day. And so, I went in and asked, and they said that there was going to be a meeting at 6 o'clock and that there might be an announcement as to who the buyer might be or what that would look like.
我可以看出银行里的气氛看起来很奇怪。我想，嗯，嘿，我想知道他们是否找到了买家，而且人们似乎听说过，因为我那天大部分时间都不在。所以我进去问了一下，他们说6点有个会议，可能会宣布买家是谁或者那看起来会是什么样子。
Todd hung around, said hello to some customers, did some banking.
托德在附近闲逛，向一些客户打招呼，处理了一些银行业务。
By this time, it was quarter to 6:00, and I went up to someone that was an executive or senior vice president of the bank. And I said, how are you doing? And they said, oh, I'm doing all right. And I could tell something was going on and they didn't want to say.
到这个时候，大约是5:45，我走到一个银行高管或高级副总裁面前。我说，你怎么样？他们说，哦，我做得还好。我能看出有事在发生，他们不想说。
And we looked across to the other side of the bank, and there was two employees adjusting pictures on the wall. And he looked over at that, and I saw his gaze go over to the wall, and so I looked over at the wall. He kind of laughed and he said, wow, he says, that reminds me of adjusting the chairs on the Titanic before it sank.
我们看了看银行的另一边，有两个员工在调整墙上的照片。他看向那边，我看到他的目光移向墙壁，所以我看了看墙。他笑了笑说，哇，他说，这让我想起在泰坦尼克号沉没前调整椅子。
And that really told me something was going down. People started to gather, and there was just this real sense of this isn't good and we're not sure what it is, but it's not good.
那真的告诉了我一些事情要发生了。人们开始聚集，有一种真实的感觉，这不是好事，我们不确定是什么，但不是好事。
Well, then it was probably very close, just a minute or two after 6 o'clock, and Mike Worthy, our CEO, came out, and he stood up and said, well, I've used the analogy that we were a ship that was taking on some water and we needed to pull up next to a bigger ship and see if they wouldn't take us on and our crew, and we thought we had a few buyers for that. But now the biggest ship that sails the seas has come alongside us and they are going to be taking us over, and that is essentially the federal government. I would like to introduce the State of Washington regulators.
嗯，那可能非常接近，就在6点后的一两分钟，麦克·沃西，我们的首席执行官，出来站起来说，嗯，我用了那个比喻，我们是一艘正在进水的船，我们需要靠上一艘更大的船，看看他们是否会接纳我们和我们的船员，我们以为我们有几个买家。但现在航行在海上的最大的船已经来到我们身边，他们将接管我们，那就是联邦政府。我想介绍华盛顿州的监管人员。
And he sat down, and the State of Washington stood up and said, we are now taking possession of the bank, of all of its assets, and we are turning them over to the receivership of the FDIC.
他坐下后，华盛顿州的人站起来说，我们现在接管银行，接管其所有资产，并将它们交给FDIC的接管部门。
6:03 PM, down the street from the bank, where he's been told by the FDIC to wait in his car, Ric Carey with Umpqua Bank hears his phone vibrate.
下午6:03，在银行下方的街道上，在FDIC告诉他在车里等的地方，安普夸银行的里克·凯里听到他的手机在震动。
At that point in time, a signal was given to myself, and basically--
在那一刻，一个信号给了我，基本上——
What kind of a signal?
什么样的信号？
It was an email.
是一封电子邮件。
What did the message say when you got it on your BlackBerry?
当你在黑莓手机上收到它时，消息说了什么？
Oh, just, it's time.
哦，只是，时间到了。
It's time.
时间到了。
Yeah, it's time. Come in.
是的，时间到了。进来。
6:05, Ric gets out of the car and starts walking toward the bank. Inside, a woman from the FDIC takes the stage.
6:05，里克下车开始走向银行。在里面，一名来自FDIC的女性登上舞台。
She said, within the next 10 minutes there will be 80 FDIC employees coming into the bank. And I looked out there, and it was dark, so I couldn't really see, and then all these people, mostly in suits and professional clothing with attorney-type briefcases, started entering the bank, just flooding into the bank.
她说，接下来的10分钟内将有80名FDIC员工进入银行。我向外看，天黑了，所以我看不太清楚，然后所有这些人，大多穿着西装和职业服装，带着律师公文包，开始进入银行，涌进银行。
And I was so awestruck at them coming in and so many of them coming into the bank that I turned around and looked over there and just kept watching them, and they just continued to come. I mean, 80? I mean, our bank had, like, 100 employees.
我对他们进来感到非常敬畏，有那么多的人进入银行，我转身看过去，一直盯着他们，他们还在继续来。我是说，80个？我是说，我们银行大约有100名员工。
And at this time, it was dark outside, and a flash flashed out in the parking lot. The flash was The Columbian newspaper taking a picture for Saturday morning's front page news that the bank had failed.
在这个时候，外面天黑了，停车场闪过一道闪光。那道闪光是《哥伦比亚报》在为周六早上的头版新闻拍照，新闻是银行倒闭了。
All of this happened, Chana, in just a matter of minutes. So, things are going through my mind like I just lost almost $25,000 worth of stock I bought four months ago in Bank of Clark County, in my bank. I mean, I'm investing in my bank. And most of the employees were shareholders.
这一切，查娜，在几分钟内就发生了。所以，我的脑子里在想，我刚损失了四个月前我在克拉克县银行，在我的银行里购买的价值近25,000美元的股票。我是说，我在投资我的银行。大多数员工都是股东。
And so, for me, there was a sense of, gosh, I think I just lost all my stock. And I looked around the bank. I saw some people crying. I saw some people with just a white face, blank stare on their face, just in shock. Some people had their hand on their face, just were like, I can't believe this, like, oh my gosh.
所以，对我来说，有一种感觉，天哪，我想我刚失去了所有的股票。我环顾银行。我看到有人在哭。我看到有些人脸色苍白，表情呆滞，陷入震惊。有些人双手蒙脸，就像，我不敢相信这个，就像，噢天哪。
6:10 PM, Ric Carey from Umpqua Bank is introduced to the confused employees of the bank he now owns. They have a whole bunch of questions running through their heads. First among them, do we get to keep our jobs? Ric can't answer that. Umpqua will only need about 1/3 of the Clark County staff, people who actually deal with customers in the branches.
下午6:10，安普夸银行的里克·凯里被介绍给困惑的银行员工，也就是他现在拥有的银行的员工。他们的脑子里有好多问题。最主要的是，我们能保住工作吗？里克无法回答。安普夸只需要克拉克县大约1/3的员工，那些真正在网点与客户打交道的人。
Most of the support staff and administration will be let go. But it's too soon to let each person know whether he or she has a job. Ric is put in charge of supervising a full-on manual hand count of all the bank's cash. A couple of his staff grab the cash and begin to count. The Bank of Clark County people watch Umpqua. The FDIC watches them both.
大多数支持人员和行政人员将被解雇。但现在告诉每个人他或她是否有工作还为时过早。里克负责监督对银行所有现金进行全面的手工清点。他的一些员工拿走了现金并开始清点。克拉克县银行的人看着安普夸。FDIC看着他们俩。
This takes three hours. Meanwhile, Bank of Clark County staff come up to Ric to introduce themselves, tell him how important they are at the bank. They're worried for their jobs. And Ric has other things on his mind.
这花了三个小时。与此同时，克拉克县银行的员工走到里克面前介绍自己，告诉他他们在银行有多重要。他们为自己的工作担心。里克心里还有别的事情。
He bought the bank from the FDIC for a pretty good price, and he only has to take the good parts, the insured deposits and the actual branch buildings. The FDIC will keep all the bad stuff, the problem loans. But there's still a lot to think about.
他以一个相当不错的价格从FDIC手中买下了这家银行，他只需要接管好的部分，即受保险的存款和实际的分行建筑。FDIC将保留所有坏的部分，即问题贷款。但还有很多事情要考虑。
You know, I have to be open in three days. What do I want that store to look like? I remember that one of the first things we did that evening was contact their plants provider and make sure that they were arranged to have 25 large plants taken out of the facility. We have a very clean operating environment at Umpqua, and plants aren't part of our MO, and so those were to be removed immediately.
你知道，我必须在三天内开业。我想要那个店看起来怎么样？我记得那天晚上我们做的第一件事是联系他们的植物供应商，确保他们安排从设施里搬走25株大型植物。我们在安普夸有一个非常干净的经营环境，植物不是我们操作模式的一部分，所以必须立即移除。
And we were looking at signage. So I basically was making a note of what signs that we needed to change, replace, how quickly we wanted to do that. We wanted to make it look like Umpqua as quickly as possible.
我们在看标识。所以我基本上记下了我们需要更换、替换哪些标志，我们想多快地这样做。我们想尽快让它看起来像安普夸。
Meanwhile, FDIC agents have already secured the vaults and the cash. They've grabbed a couple hard drives. Now they need to inventory the entire bank. Every account needs to be transferred to Umpqua. The bank has to open its doors Tuesday morning. Monday was Martin Luther King Day, bank holiday.
与此同时，FDIC特工已经确保了金库和现金的安全。他们抓住了几个硬盘。现在他们需要盘点整个银行。每个账户都需要转移到安普夸。银行必须在周二早上开门。周一是马丁·路德·金日，银行假期。
To get all this done, the FDIC needs the Bank of Clark County staff to help them, to show them where the files are, who the customers are, how to get to the bathroom. And so, at 6:15 PM, the FDIC makes an announcement: we need you all to sign in on this sheet of paper, everyone. As of right now, for the weekend, you're all temporary employees of the FDIC. We're going to need you to stay late tonight, work through the weekend. You will be paid for your time. We'll feed you. We need your help.
为了完成所有这一切，FDIC需要克拉克县银行的员工帮助他们，向他们展示文件在哪里，客户是谁，如何去洗手间。所以，在下午6:15，FDIC宣布：我们需要你们都在这张纸上签名，所有人。从现在起，周末，你们都是FDIC的临时员工。我们需要你们今晚留下来工作，整个周末都在工作。你们的时间会得到报酬。我们会提供食物。我们需要你们的帮助。
Ken Moody was vice president of information systems at the Bank of Clark County.
肯·穆迪是克拉克县银行信息系统副总裁。
Again, most of us were planning on leaving at the end of the day. And so, after that announcement was made, we had phone calls to make, call our families. My daughter had a seventh birthday that we were going to go to.
同样，我们大多数人计划在一天结束时离开。所以，那项公告宣布后，我们得打电话，给家人打电话。我女儿有一个第七岁生日，我们要去参加。
Take your time.
慢慢来。
Sorry. I didn't anticipate being this emotional about it. Kind of silly.
抱歉。我没想到会对此感到这么情绪化。有点傻。
6:20 PM, agents take over offices, storage rooms, hallways, any space available. They tape handmade signs to the doors, written on 8.5 x 11 sheets of printer paper, saying things like, audit, security, investigations. It's a little chaotic.
下午6:20，特工接管了办公室、储藏室、走廊、任何可用的空间。他们用胶带把手工标志贴在门上，写在8.5 x 11英寸的打印纸上，说着像“审计”、“安全”、“调查”之类的话。有点混乱。
The FDIC moves room to room. They go through files, transfer accounts, they change the website, they check the safe deposit boxes, make sure everything that's supposed to be in there is in there. They go through desk drawers. They toss out bank letterhead.
FDIC逐个房间移动。他们翻阅文件，转移账户，他们修改网站，他们检查保险箱，确保所有应该在里面的东西都在里面。他们翻阅抽屉。他们扔掉银行信头。
Once agents have scanned a room for all critical information, they place a green dot on its door frame. Then they take all that paperwork, all the hard drives, all the files, and the FDIC has to reconstruct the bank's entire balance sheet. It has to know what it's selling to Umpqua, what's actually there.
一旦特工扫描了一个房间的所有关键信息，他们就会在门框上贴一个绿点。然后他们把所有那些文书工作、所有硬盘、所有文件都拿走，FDIC必须重构银行的整个资产负债表。它必须知道它在卖给安普夸什么，实际上有什么。
Any account with a balance up to $250,000 is fully insured by the FDIC. If the bank doesn't have the money to cover the balance, the government will pay it out. But some people have more than $250,000, and there are business accounts and loans, and it gets complicated.
任何余额高达250,000美元的账户都由FDIC全额保险。如果银行没有钱支付余额，政府会支付。但有些人有超过250,000美元，还有商业账户和贷款，事情变得复杂。
Some is covered, some is not. The FDIC now sorts all that out.
有些是承保的，有些不是。FDIC现在整理这一切。
Things started happening very quickly and with what seemed to be a lot of precision.
事情开始非常迅速地发生，而且看起来非常精确。
6:25 PM, in the IT department, three agents approach Ken Moody, the IT guy. They hand him a thumb drive. Please plug this in, they say. It has all the software to change your computer systems over to Umpqua Bank.
下午6:25，在IT部门，三名特工接近IT人员肯·穆迪。他们递给他一个拇指驱动器。请插入这个，他们说。它有所有软件，可以将你的计算机系统切换到安普夸银行。
That was kind of a fascinating part about it. So it was almost like, on one hand, it's very sad, you have the death of a loved one. But at the same time, it was like watching an autopsy being performed by a really skillful surgeon. They just came in and just sliced and diced and broke the bank up into different pieces and threw them into different buckets and did it with great efficiency.
那是其中相当迷人的一部分。所以这几乎就像，一方面，非常悲伤，你有亲人的死亡。但同时，这就像看着一个非常熟练的外科医生在进行尸检。他们只是进来，切碎并把银行分成不同的部分，把它们扔进不同的桶里，并且非常高效地做到了这一点。
An autopsy of the work that you'd been doing.
对你一直在做的工作的尸检。
Yeah. Well, yeah, an autopsy of everything that we'd been creating over the last 10 years.
是的。嗯，是的，对我们在过去10年里一直在创造的一切的尸检。
At the Bank of Clark County, everyone I talked to said this one thing about the FDIC that stuck with me, something you don't often hear about a government agency, that it did a really good job, that the agents were kind, courteous, and efficient. In fact, everything is ordered, structured. Everything, even how and when to grieve.
在克拉克县银行，我交谈过的每个人都说了关于FDIC的一件事，让我印象深刻，关于一个政府机构你很少听到的事情，那就是它做得非常好，特工们善良、礼貌且高效。事实上，一切都是有序、有结构的。一切，甚至如何以及何时悲伤。
Here's Lisa Stapleton. She was an assistant loan officer with the bank.
这是丽莎·斯台普顿。她是该银行的助理贷款官员。
So many of the people who came in from the FDIC got to where they were because they were part of a bank that failed. And they were all like, you know what? We've been where you are, and we understand, and it's going to be fine. So they were really nice.
许多从FDIC过来的人之所以走到这一步，是因为他们曾经所属的银行倒闭了。他们都说，你知道吗？我们去过你现在所在的地方，我们理解，一切都会好起来的。所以他们真的很好。
The Bank of Clark County had 100 employees and assets of $446 million, which, if you're not used to bank numbers, is a really small bank. But it took 80 FDIC agents, about 50 Bank of Clark County employees, and 100 Umpqua employees working around the clock for three days to take it over and have it reopened for business.
克拉克县银行有100名员工和4.46亿美元的资产，如果你不习惯银行数字，这是一家非常小的银行。但接管它并重新开业，花了80名FDIC特工、大约50名克拉克县银行员工和100名安普夸员工连续三天全天候工作。
Most of the largest banks in trouble right now, Citibank, Bank of America, are about 6,000 times the size of Bank of Clark County, not to mention much, much more complicated. So the Secretary of Treasury's latest plan to save the banks does everything it can to avoid using this process on those big banks.
目前陷入困境的最大银行，花旗银行、美国银行，规模大约是克拉克县银行的6000倍，更不用说复杂得多了。所以财政部长拯救银行的最新计划尽其所能避免在大银行上使用这个过程。
When you do this to a little bank, it's called receivership. When you do it to a big bank, people start to throw around the word nationalization. Every week, FDIC agents get more experience taking over banks. In the 10 weeks since they took over the Bank of Clark County, 18 more banks have failed, bringing us to a grand total of 20 failures since the start of this year, before this weekend, that is, when most likely they'll add a few more to that list.
当你对一家小银行这样做时，它被称为接管。当你对一家大银行这样做时，人们开始抛出“国有化”这个词。每周，FDIC特工在接管银行方面获得更多经验。在他们接管克拉克县银行后的10周内，又有18家银行倒闭，使我们今年年初以来的倒闭总数达到20家，那是在这个周末之前，也就是那时他们很可能会在那份名单上增加更多。
Chana Joffe-Walt in Seattle. She's a regular contributor to the Planet Money podcast, which you can hear at npr.org/money.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特在西雅图。她是Planet Money播客的常客，你可以在npr.org/money上听到。
Act three, Short-Circuit City.
第三幕，短路城市。
Among the big chain stores that have gone out of business in this recession, Circuit City, the second biggest electronics store in the country, shutting down after 60 years. Earlier this month, the Chicago Tribune described the atmosphere in a Chicago Circuit City outlet the week before it shut down as funereal. Quote, "employees, wearing sullen faces, who, when asked if a display model Sony VAIO laptop missing nine keys is still $623.99, answer with a mechanical, leave me the hell alone, 'yep.'"
在此次经济衰退中倒闭的大型连锁店中，美国第二大电子商店Circuit City在60年后关闭。本月早些时候，《芝加哥论坛报》将关闭前一周芝加哥一家Circuit City分店的气氛描述为葬礼般。引用，“员工们戴着闷闷不乐的脸，当被问及一台缺少九个按键的展示模型索尼VAIO笔记本电脑是否仍然是623.99美元时，他们会以一种机械的、别打扰我的‘ yep’来回答。”
It's not as if they object to helping, but they're also texting while ringing up customers at the checkout line. Because, really, what are they going to do? Fire them? The day after that was published in the paper, the reporter who wrote that story-- his name is Kevin Pang-- got an email from one of that store's employees.
并不是他们反对帮忙，但他们在结账柜台为顾客结账时也在发短信。因为，真的，他们能做什么？开除他们？在那篇报道发表后的第二天，写那个故事的记者——他的名字叫凯文·庞——收到了一封来自那家商店员工的电子邮件。
First, let me say that I enjoyed your article.
首先，让我说我很喜欢你的文章。
That's Jonathan Mullens. We invited him here to read his email.
那是乔纳森·穆伦斯。我们邀请他来这里阅读他的电子邮件。
Second, there's a better-than-average chance that I am the leave-me-the-hell-alone-yep guy from your article. Let me tell you why the morale in the store is the way that it is.
第二，我有很大机会就是你文章中那个“别打扰我”的家伙。让我告诉你为什么商店里的士气是这样的。
At this point, we all want it to be over with. I cannot name a single person here who wishes this hell to continue. Our attitude is a direct result of the customers who have come into the store during this liquidation. Many of them are rude and complain to us about everything. Why does this cost so much? Why isn't this discounted more? That's all I get off? How much are you hiding in the back? I can get it cheaper at Best Buy.
在这一点上，我们都希望这一切结束。我叫不出任何一个希望这场地狱继续下去的人。我们的态度是这轮清算中进入商店的顾客的直接结果。他们中的许多人很粗鲁，对我们抱怨一切。为什么这要这么贵？为什么这没有更多折扣？我就得到这些？你后面还藏了多少？我在Best Buy能买到更便宜的。
If I hear that last one again, I might choke the person that says it. I now view Circuit City as a sickly old relative who you just want to die so the suffering can stop and you don't have to deal with it anymore. Again, I enjoyed your article and found the humor in it. We are not bad people here. We are just tired and beaten.
如果我再听到最后那句，我可能会掐死说那句话的人。我现在把Circuit City看作一个病入膏肓的老亲戚，你只想让他死，这样痛苦就可以停止，你就不必再处理它了。再次，我喜欢你的文章并从中发现了幽默。我们不是坏人。我们只是累了，被打垮了。
34,000 people lost their jobs in the liquidation. Some of them had worked at Circuit City for years. In January, when the stores began selling off their last merchandise, the website Gizmodo invited Circuit City employees to write in and describe what it was like in the trenches of liquidation. Gizmodo published their emails in a story called, "Their Final Words as Grunts of Circuit City."
34,000人在清算中失去了工作。他们中的一些人在Circuit City工作了多年。1月，当商店开始出售最后商品时，网站Gizmodo邀请Circuit City员工写信描述清算前线是什么样子。Gizmodo发表了他们的电子邮件，故事名为“他们作为Circuit City苦力的最后话语”。
And what you're going to hear now are excerpts from those dispatches, along with other emails that we solicited from Circuit City employees in stores around the country, Peoria, North Carolina, Florida, Pennsylvania. The way that it worked is that special liquidation companies came in to run the stores during the last few weeks, to sell off the final merchandise, as much of it as possible, because the more money they brought in the door, the more they could pay off creditors and, not incidentally, the more profit the liquidation companies got to keep themselves. Which explains why one of the very first things they did in most stores was raise prices.
现在你们要听到的是这些调度摘录，以及我们从全国各地，皮奥里亚、北卡罗来纳、佛罗里达、宾夕法尼亚的Circuit City员工那里征集的其他电子邮件。它的工作方式是特殊的清算公司在最后几周进来运营商店，出售最后的商品，尽可能多地销售，因为他们带进门的钱越多，他们就能偿还债权人更多，而且并非巧合，清算公司自己获得的利润就越多。这解释了为什么他们在大多数商店做的第一件事就是提高价格。
The day after we learned we were closing, a liquidator showed up at our store in Peoria. His name was Chip. He worked for one of the liquidation companies, which meant he was in charge of our store now. One of my coworkers would only refer to Chip as The A-hole, but to me he seemed like a decent enough guy.
在我们得知我们要关闭后的第二天，一个清算人出现在我们在皮奥里亚的商店。他的名字叫奇普。他为清算公司之一工作，这意味着他现在负责我们的商店。我的一位同事只会叫奇普为“混蛋”，但对我来说他看起来像个足够体面的人。
Then he gave us the new rules. First, on Sunday, most of our prices were being raised-- yes, I said raised-- to MSRP, manufacturer's suggested retail price. Most items would start off at 10% off MSRP. Also, we no longer accepted checks, the price guarantee was gone, all sales were final, and we would no longer take the Circuit City credit card.
然后他给了我们新规则。首先，在周日，我们的大部分价格被提高——是的，我说提高——到MSRP，制造商建议零售价。大多数商品将以MSRP的10%折扣开始。此外，我们不再接受支票，价格保证没了，所有销售是最终的，我们将不再接受Circuit City信用卡。
We had a huge influx of customers who'd been waiting for us to go under so that they could get the store closing prices, only to discover that the prices were now higher than they were before. The amazing thing is that it worked. People were buying things at a higher price than they would have before liquidation. In the first three days of liquidation, we'd made more money than we had in a week.
我们涌入了大量顾客，他们一直等着我们倒闭，这样他们就能得到商店倒闭的价格，结果却发现价格比以前更高了。令人惊奇的是它奏效了。人们以比清算前更高的价格购买东西。在清算的前三天，我们赚的钱比一周还多。
When the doors opened on the first day of liquidation, it was obvious that we were severely understaffed. When customers complained that they couldn't find help, I explained that we weren't staffed for the rush because we'd only found out we were going out of business the day before. That's why you're going out of business, one woman sneered. You don't plan ahead.
清算第一天开门时，很明显我们严重人手不足。当顾客抱怨找不到人帮忙时，我解释说我们没有为这种抢购准备人员，因为我们前一天才发现我们要倒闭了。这就是你们倒闭的原因，一个女人讥讽道。你们不提前计划。
"That's why you're going out of business" became the customers' mantra. It never came after something intelligent like, "the one-price promise was one of the stupidest campaigns in the history of retail, and that's why you're going out of business." Or, "two years ago, your company laid off 3,400 seasoned employees for making too much money and replaced them with young and inexperienced people, and that's why you're going out of business."
“这就是你们倒闭的原因”成了顾客的口头禅。它从来没有出现在像“单一价格承诺是零售史上最愚蠢的活动之一，这就是你们倒闭的原因”这样聪明的事情之后。或者，“两年前，你们公司因为报酬过高解雇了3400名经验丰富的员工，并用年轻且缺乏经验的人取代了他们，这就是你们倒闭的原因。”
I was working loss prevention at the door one evening, and a guy came in and said, hey, has anyone found a wallet? I think I left it at the cart. I haven't heard anything. Let me ask over the walkie. No, I'm sorry, we haven't found a wallet.
有一天晚上我在门口做损失预防工作，一个家伙进来问，嘿，有人捡到钱包吗？我想我把它落在购物车了。我没听到任何消息。让我用对讲机问一下。不，对不起，我们没捡到钱包。
He made a disgusted face and walked away, then turned and yelled, no wonder you guys are going out of business. I yelled back, yes, sir, 34,000 people are losing their jobs because you lost your wallet. Thanks for clarifying.
他做了一个厌恶的表情走开了，然后转身大喊，难怪你们这帮家伙要倒闭。我回喊道，是的，先生，34,000人正在因为你丢了钱包而失去工作。谢谢澄清。
I really don't know where all the anger comes from. I'm sorry I can't sell you a GPS for 70% off. I'm sorry we don't have any Wiis. I'm sorry I can't sell you that flat screen TV for $300. I'm sorry I can't take your check or Circuit City credit card as a payment. I'm sorry. I was simply a car stereo installer. I'm doing the best I can to help you. If my best isn't enough, I'm sorry.
我真的不知道所有的愤怒从何而来。抱歉我不能以7折的价格卖给你GPS。抱歉我们没有任何Wii。抱歉我不能以300美元的价格卖给你那台平板电视。抱歉我不能接受你的支票或Circuit City信用卡作为付款。抱歉。我只是一个汽车音响安装工。我正在尽我所能帮助你。如果我尽力了还不够，我很抱歉。
The best way to describe a liquidation sale is what I call anti-retail. In regular retail, the more you sell and the better you do, the more likely you are to keep your job. In anti-retail, the more you sell and the better you do, the faster you lose your job.
描述清算销售的最好方式是我称之为“反零售”。在正常零售中，你卖得越多，做得越好，你越有可能保住工作。在反零售中，你卖得越多，做得越好，你失去工作的速度就越快。
Store morale really started falling when we began emptying whole sections and roping them off with yellow caution tape, like at a CSI crime scene. But the mood hit an all-time low when we had to put up the big 10-days-to-close sign. At least then we could finally answer the customer's number-one question, when is your last day? with, I'll be fired on Sunday, March 8.
当我们开始清空整个区域并用黄色警戒线围起来时，就像在CSI犯罪现场一样，商店士气真正开始下降。但当我们不得不挂起大大的“离关闭还有10天”的标志时，心情降到了最低点。至少那时我们终于可以回答顾客的头号问题：“你们最后一天是什么时候？”回答说：“我将在3月8日星期日被解雇。”
Only a few weeks into liquidation, XM Radio cut the signal to our store. Without music the place was eerily quiet. Then Canteen Vending pulled the soda and candy machines out of the break room. One of the drivers told me that the company was afraid they wouldn't get their money. I'm not sure what that means since you have to put money in the machine before it gives you something. I asked the driver what we were supposed to do now for soda, and he just shrugged his shoulders as he strapped the machine down for transport.
清算仅几周后，XM电台切断了我们商店的信号。没有音乐，这个地方安静得令人毛骨悚然。然后Canteen Vending把休息室里的汽水和糖果机搬走了。司机之一告诉我，公司担心他们拿不到钱。我不确定那是什么意思，因为你必须在机器里放钱，它才会给你东西。我问司机我们现在汽水该怎么办，他只是耸了耸肩，把机器绑好运输。
Recruiters stopped by the store to advertise jobs. There had been at least two Amway-like sales companies and three auto parts stores. A coworker told me that he had an interview with one of these stores, and that they pay just slightly more than minimum wage. Of course, the armed services had made their presence felt, too. Anytime one of the younger kids sees someone in the store in full military dress, it's suddenly time for their break.
招聘人员到商店打广告招聘。至少有两家类似安利的销售公司和三家汽车零部件商店。一位同事告诉我，他去其中一家商店面试，他们支付的报酬只比最低工资高一点点。当然，武装部队也让他们感受到了他们的存在。每当年轻一点的孩子看到商店里有人穿着全套军装时，就突然到了他们休息的时间了。
Our liquidation manager puts on a good front of being nice, asking how our job applications are coming, and greeting us energetically when he sees us. But he, just like everyone else, is looking out for himself. Early in the liquidation process, he hinted that we would be allowed to stash things, hide stuff that we wanted to buy in the warehouse, until the last day, when we'd receive the best possible discount.
我们的清算经理装出一副好人的样子，询问我们的求职申请进展如何，并在见到我们时充满活力地打招呼。但他，像其他人一样，是在为自己着想。在清算过程的早期，他暗示我们可以藏匿东西，把我们想买的东西藏在仓库里，直到最后一天，那时我们将获得尽可能好的折扣。
Customers also tried stashing things under our shelving to come back and dig up later. We searched weekly, often turning up new merchandise to put right back out for sale. The liquidation manager promised to look the other way for our stashed items, but a month later he reneged on the deal. Incidentally, about a week before we closed, the newspaper reported that the liquidator, while working at our sister store, was arrested and charged with stealing merchandise.
顾客也试图把东西藏在我们的货架下，回来以后再挖出来。我们每周都会搜查，经常发现新的商品放回原处出售。清算经理承诺对我们藏匿的物品视而不见，但一个月后他违背了协议。顺便说一句，在我们关闭前大约一周，报纸报道清算人在我们的姐妹商店工作时被逮捕，并被指控盗窃商品。
With two days left, we were down to 17 laptop computers, 33 CDs, eight cameras, and a few printers. Basically, everything in the store that wasn't nailed down, and some things that were, had or would be sold, including a case of tampons for the vending machine in the women's restroom and a 12-foot circular rug covered in Circuit City logos. One of our associates was vacuuming when a customer walked up and offered to buy the vacuum right out of his hands. He was told to come back on the last day.
剩下两天时，我们只剩下17台笔记本电脑，33张CD，8台相机和几台打印机。基本上，商店里没有钉在墙上的所有东西，以及一些钉上的东西，都已经或将被出售，包括一盒供女洗手间自动售货机使用的卫生棉条，以及一张覆盖着Circuit City标志的12英尺圆形地毯。我们的一名员工正在吸尘，一名顾客走过来要求直接从他手中买下真空吸尘器。他被告知最后一天再来。
The employees were actually in a great mood. We realized we made it to the end, and it was kind of a badge of honor to stick it out. The liquidator bought us lunch and the customers were well-behaved and courteous. The cashiers set up a tip jar at the register, and it was pretty full by the end of the day. Too bad they didn't think of it sooner.
员工们其实心情很好。我们意识到我们坚持到了最后，坚持到底成了一种荣誉勋章。清算人请我们吃了午饭，顾客们表现得很好，很有礼貌。收银员在收银台设了一个小费罐，到一天结束时已经相当满了。真可惜他们没有早点想到这一点。
At 4:46 on March 8, the next-to-to-last cash register was closed. The only cashier still working was Brenda, the same person who had rung up Peoria's very first transaction when the store opened in 1994. Brenda was one of the six people from our store, and one of 3,400 nationwide, who got terminated two years ago when the CEO, Phil Schoonover, got the bright idea that some of our experienced staff made too much money. But she'd gotten permission from our manager to be there at the end.
3月8日下午4:46，倒数第二个收银机关闭了。唯一还在工作的收银员是布兰达，也就是1994年商店开业时为皮奥里亚完成第一笔交易的那个人。布兰达是我们店里的六个人之一，也是全国3400人中在两年前被解雇的人之一，当时首席执行官菲尔·斯库诺弗有一个天才的想法，认为我们一些经验丰富的员工报酬过高。但她得到了经理的许可，可以在最后时刻出现在那里。
At 5:10, Brenda rang up our last sale, a single USB printer cable, originally priced at $33.99, sold for $2.16 including tax. Someone who watches way too much ER called out, call it, time of death, 5:11 PM.
5:10，布兰达结了我们最后一笔账，一根USB打印机电缆，原价33.99美元，以2.16美元（含税）售出。某个看《急诊室的故事》太多的人大喊，报时吧，死亡时间，下午5:11。
Another associate and I read the closing instructions. We went through the store and cut off most of the breakers for power. We cleaned up, clocked out for the last time, and went home. The next day, the store managers would make the final cash deposit and ship off any remaining merchandise. They'd turn off all the lights, lock the door, and mail the last key off to corporate.
另一名同事和我阅读了关闭说明。我们穿过商店，切断了大部分电源断路器。我们打扫卫生，最后一次打卡下班，然后回家。第二天，店经理将进行最后的现金存款，并将运走任何剩余的商品。他们会关掉所有的灯，锁上门，并把最后一一把钥匙寄给总公司。
Companies often motivate associates by telling them how one person can make a difference. The closing of Circuit City shows how far from reality that truly is.
公司经常通过告诉员工一个人如何能产生影响来激励他们。Circuit City的关闭显示了这与现实相差有多远。
We busted our butts to make Circuit City store number 3167 a success, but in the grand scheme of things, it didn't matter. It was like the corporate executives took us for a ride, then dropped us off in the middle of nowhere. Every bit of hard work that I did, every extended warranty that I sold, if I hadn't done any of that, I'd still be in the same position I am today. I'm out of a job, and there wasn't anything we could do about it.
我们拼命工作让Circuit City 3167号店取得成功，但在宏伟的计划中，这并不重要。就像公司高管带我们兜了一圈，然后把我们丢在了荒郊野外。我所做的每一份努力，我卖出的每一份延长保修，如果我没做其中任何事情，我今天仍然处于同样的位置。我失业了，而且我们无能为力。
Those were all former Circuit City employees. Only one of the five, James Armitage in Florida, has found another job. Allen in North Carolina, the car stereo installer, is planning to go to school this summer to become either a nurse or an electrician. People always need nurses and electricity, he wrote us. John Gallagher, Chris Evans, and Jonathan Mullens are still looking.
以上都是Circuit City的前员工。五个人中只有一个人，佛罗里达州的詹姆斯·阿米蒂奇，找到了另一份工作。北卡罗来纳州的艾伦，那个汽车音响安装工，计划今年夏天去学校成为一名护士或电工。他写信给我们说，人们总是需要护士和电。约翰·加拉格尔、克里斯·埃文斯和乔纳森·穆伦斯仍在寻找。
[RAP SONG] Starting lineup. D. Baxter, B. Smith, J. Milligan, baby. 4506, yeah. Where you go to get your gifts in time? Circuit City up, Best Buy down. You want gifts? Then you better come around. Circuit City up, Best Buy down.
[说唱歌曲] 首发阵容。D.巴克斯特，B.史密斯，J.米利根，宝贝。4506，耶。你在哪里及时买到你的礼物？Circuit City上升，Best Buy下降。你想要礼物？那最好过来。Circuit City上升，Best Buy下降。
Well, this song was actually written and performed by employees of Circuit City store number 4506 in North Little Rock, Arkansas. Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and me, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Andy Dixon. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
嗯，这首歌实际上是由阿肯色州北小石城的Circuit City 4506号店的员工编写和演唱的。我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。安迪·迪克森提供制作帮助。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。杰西卡·霍珀提供音乐帮助。
Dirt, dirt, you live on dirt. Ho, ho, ho, ho.
泥土，泥土，你住在泥土上。呵呵呵呵。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。